you were the first ever guest on this
podcast episode number one so first of
all Max I just have to say uh thank you
for giving me a chance thank you for
starting this journey it's been an
incredible journey just thank you for um
sitting down with me and just acting
like I'm somebody who matters that I'm
somebody who's interesting to talk to
and uh thank you for doing it I meant a
lot all right thanks to you for putting
your heart and soul into this I know
when you delve into controversial topics
it's inevitable to get hit by what what
happened let's talk about the slings and
arrows and stuff and I really admire
this it's in an era you know where
YouTube videos are too long and now it
has to be like a 20 minute Tick Tock 20
second Tick Tock clip it's just so
refreshing to see you going exactly
against all of the advice and doing this
with these really long form things and
the people appreciate it you know
reality is nuanced and uh thanks for
and sharing it that way uh so let me ask
you again the first question I've ever
asked on this podcast episode number one
talking to you do you think there's
intelligent life out there in the
universe let's revisit that question do
you have any updates what's your view
when you look out to the Stars so when
we look out to the Stars
if you define our universe the way most
astrophysicists do not as all of space
but the spherical region of space that
we can see with our telescopes from
which light has the time to reach us
since our big bang
I'm in the minority I I'm
estimate that we are the only life
in this spherical volume that has uh
invented Internet radio has gotten our
level of tech and um if that's true
then it puts a lot of responsibility on
us to not mess this one up because if
it's true it means that life is is quite
rare and we are stewards of this one
spark of advanced Consciousness which if
we nurture it then
help it grow it eventually life can
spread from here out into much of our
universe and we can have this amazing
future at worse if we instead um are
Reckless with the technology we build
and just snuff it out through the
stupidity
or in fighting then
maybe the rest of cosmic history in our
Universal is just going to be a plenty
for empty benches but I I do think that
we are actually very likely to get
visited by aliens
alien intelligence quite soon but I
think we are going to be building that
alien intelligence
so
uh we're going to give birth
to an intelligent alien civilization
unlike anything that human the evolution
here on Earth was able to create in
terms of the path the biological path it
took yeah and it's going to be much more
alien than
cats or even the most exotic animal on
the planet right now because it will not
have been created through the usual
darwinian competition where it
necessarily cares about
self-preservation is afraid of death
any of those things
the space of alien Minds it's just that
you can build it's just so much faster
than what evolution will give you
and with that also comes a great
responsibility but the the for us to
make sure that the kind of Minds we
create or this kind of Minds that um
it's good to create Minds that will uh
share our values and and be good for
Humanity in life and also mind don't
create Minds that don't suffer
do you try to visualize the full space
of alien Minds that AI could be to try
to consider all the different kinds of
intelligences
sort of generalizing what humans are
able to do to the full spectrum of an
intelligent creatures entities could do
I try but
I would say I fail I mean it's
it's very difficult for a human mind
really grapple with
something still complete the alien I
mean even even for us right if we just
try to imagine how would it feel if we
were completely indifferent towards
death or individuality if we
even if you just imagine that for
example
you could just copy my knowledge of how
to speak Swedish boom now you can speak
Swedish
and you could copy any of my cool
experiences and then you could delete
the ones you didn't like in your own
life just like that it
it would already change quite a lot
about how you feel as a human being
right if you probably spend less effort
studying things if you just copy them
and you might be less afraid of death
because if the plane you're on starts to
crash you just be like oh shucks I'm
gonna I haven't backed my brain up for
four hours so I'm gonna lose this all
this wonderful experiences of this
flight
we might also start feeling
more like compassionate maybe with other
people if we can severely share each
other's experiences and our knowledge
and feel more like a hive mind it's very
hard though I I really
feel very humble about this
to to Grapple with it that the how it
might actually feel that the the one
thing which is so obvious though it's I
think is just really worth reflecting on
is because the mind space of possible
intelligence is so different from ours
it's very dangerous if we assume they're
going to be like us or anything like us
well there's a
the entirety of uh human written history
has been through poetry through novels
been trying to describe through
philosophy
try and describe the Human Condition and
what's entailed in it like just like you
said fear of death and all those kinds
of things what is love and all of that
changes yeah if you have a different
kind of intelligence yeah all of it the
entirety all those poems they're trying
to sneak up to what the hell it means to
be human all of that changes how AI
concerns and uh existential crises that
AI experiences how that clashes with the
human existential crisis The Human
Condition yeah it's hard to hard to
Fathom how to predict it's hard but it's
fascinating to think about also even in
the best case scenario where we don't
lose control of over the ever more
powerful AI that we're building to
other humans whose goals we think are
horrible and where we don't lose control
to the machines
and AI
provides the things we want even then
you get into questions do you touched
here you know maybe it's the struggle
that it's actually hard to do things is
part of the things that gives us meaning
as well right so for example I found it
so shocking that this new Microsoft gpt4
commercial that they put together has
this woman talking about
showing this demo how she's going to
give a graduation speech to her beloved
daughter and she asks gpt4 to write it
it was freaking 200 words or so if I
realized that my parents couldn't be
bothered struggling a little bit to
write
200 words and Outsource that to their
computer I would feel really offended
actually
and so I'm I wonder if um eliminating
too much of this struggle from our
existence
do you think that would also take away a
little bit of
what it means to be human yeah
we can't even predict I had somebody
mentioned to me that they use they
started using uh
with a 3.5 and not 4.0
to write what they really feel to a
person
and they have a temper issue and they're
basically trying to get Chad gbt to
rewrite it in a nicer way to get the
point across but we write in a nicer way
so we're even removing the inner
from our communication so I don't you
know there's some positive
aspects of that but mostly it's just the
transformation of how humans communicate
and it's scary because so much of our
society is based on this glue of
communication and if that we're now
using AI as the medium of communication
that that does the language for us uh so
much of the emotion that's Laden in
human communication so much of the
intent
that's going to be handled by an
outsourced AI how does that change
everything how how does it change the
internal state of how we feel about
other human beings what makes us lonely
what makes us excited yeah what makes us
afraid how we fall in love all that kind
of stuff yeah
for me personally I have to confess the
challenge is one of the things that
really makes my life feel
meaningful you know
if I go hiking mountain with my wife may
I if I don't want to just press the
button and be at the top but I want to
struggle and come up there sweaty and
feel wow we did this in the same way
I want to constantly work on myself to
become a better person if I say
something in Anger that I regret I want
to go back and and really work on myself
rather than just tell an AI just from
now on always filter what I write so I
don't have to work on myself because
then I'm not growing
yeah but then again it could be like
with chess an AI
wants it significantly obviously
supersedes the performance of humans it
will live in its own world and provide
maybe a uh flourishing Civilizations for
humans but we humans will continue
hiking mountains and playing our games
even though AI is so much smarter so
much stronger so much Superior in every
single way just like with chess yeah so
that that I mean that's one possible
hopeful trajectory here is that humans
will continue to Human
uh and AI will just be a
kind of
a a medium that enables The Human
Experience to flourish yeah
I would phrase that as rebranding
ourselves from Homo sapiens to homo
sentience you know right now it's
sapiens the ability to be intelligent
we've even put it in our species name
we're
branding ourselves as the smartest
yeah information processing
empathy on the planet that's clearly
gonna
change if AI continues ahead
so maybe we should focus on the
experience instead the subjective
experience that we have with homo
sentience and and so that's what's
really valuable the love the connection
the other things
and get off our high horses and get rid
of this hubris that only we can um do we
do integrals so Consciousness the
subjective experience is a fundamental
value
to what it means to be human make that
make that the priority
that feels like a hopeful direction to
me but that also requires more
compassion not just towards other humans
because they happen to be the smartest
on the planet but also towards all our
other fellow creatures on this planet
and that I personally feel right now
we're treating a lot of farm animals
horribly for example and the excuse
we're using is oh they're not as smart
as us but if we get that we're not that
smart in the grand scheme of things
either in the post aiepoc you know
then surely we should value
the subjective experience of a cow also
well
allow me to briefly look at the book
which at this point is becoming more and
more Visionary that you've written I
guess over five years ago life 3.0
so first of all 3.0 what's 1.0 what's
2.0 was 3.0 and how's that Vision sort
of evolve the vision in the book evolved
to today life 1.0 is really dumb like
bacteria and that it can't actually
learn anything at all during the
lifetime the learning just comes from
this genetic
process from one generation to the next
Life 2.0 Is Us and other animals which
have brains which can learn during their
lifetime a great deal right so
and um you know you were born without
being able to speak English and at some
point you decided hey I want to upgrade
my software let's install an
English-speaking module
so you did
and life 3.0 does not exist yet can
cannot replace not only its software the
way we can but also it's Hardware
and um that's where we're heading
towards at high speed we're already
maybe 2.1 because we can you know put in
a
an artificial knee uh pacemaker
etc etc and if neuralink and other
companies succeed will be like 2.2 Etc
but uh well the Company's trying to
build AGI are trying to make is of
course full 3.0 and you can put that
intelligence into something that also
has no
biological basis whatsoever so let's
constrain some more capabilities just
like the lead from 1.0 to 2.0 there is
nevertheless you speaking so harshly
about bacteria so disrespectfully about
bacteria there is still the same kind of
magic there
that permeates Life 2.0 and uh and 3.0
it seems like maybe the thing that's
truly powerful
about life intelligence and
Consciousness was already there in 1.0
is it possible
I think we should be humble and not be
so quick
make everything binary and say either
it's there or it's not clearly there's a
there's a great spectrum and there is
even controversy by whether some
unicellular or organisms like amoebas
can maybe learn a little bit
you know after all so apologies if I
offended anything there yeah it wasn't
by intent it was more that I wanted to
talk up how cool it is to actually have
a brain yeah where you can learn
dramatically within your lifetime
typical human and and the higher up you
get from 1.0 to 2.0 to 3.0 the more you
become the captain of your own death of
your own ship the master of your own
destiny and the less you become a slave
to whatever Evolution gave you right
by upgrading our software we can be so
different from previous generations and
even from our parents
much more so than even a bacterium you
know no offense to them
and if you can also swap out your
Hardware take any physical form you want
of course it's really the sky's the
limit
yeah so the
it accelerates the rate at which you can
perform the competition computation that
determines your destiny yeah and I think
it's it's worth
commenting a bit on what you means in
this context also if you swap things out
a lot right now
this is controversial but my
current
understanding is that that you know
life is best thought of not as a bag of
meat or even a bag of
Elementary particles but rather as in as
um
a system which can process information
and retain its own complexity
even though nature is always trying to
mess it up so
it's all about information processing
and
that makes it a lot like something like
a wave in the ocean which is not it's
it's water molecules right the water
molecules bob up and down but the wave
moves forward it's an information
pattern in the same way ulex
you're not the same atoms as during the
first time you did with me you've
swapped out most of them but still you
yeah and
the the information pattern is still
there and um
if you if you could swap out your arms
and whatever
you can still have this kind of
continuity it becomes much more
sophisticated sort of wave forward and
time where the information lives on I I
lost both of my parents uh since since I
last podcast and and it actually gives
me a lot of Solace that
this way of thinking about them they
haven't entirely died because
a lot of mommy and daddy's um
sorry I'm getting a little emotional
here but a lot of their values
and ideas and even jokes and so on they
haven't gone away right some of them
live on I can carry on some of them and
they also live on a lot of other and a
lot of other people so in this sense
even with Life 2.0 we can to some extent
already transcend
our physical bodies and our death
and particularly if you can share your
own information your own ideas with many
others like you do in your podcast
then
you know that's the closest immortality
we can get with our biobodies you carry
a little bit of them in you yes yeah
uh do you miss them you miss your mom
and dad of course of course what did you
learn about life from them if it can
take a bit
of a tangent
on so many things
um
for starters my my Fascination for Math
and the physical mysteries of our
University thinking I got a lot of that
for my dad but I think my obsession for
really big questions and Consciousness
and so on that actually came mostly from
my mom
and
what I got from both of them which is
very core part of really who I am I
think is is
um
this um
just feeling comfortable with
not buying into what everybody else is
saying
what I think is right
they both
very much just you know did their own
thing and sometimes they got flagged for
it and it did it anyway
that's why you've always been an
inspiration to me that you're at the top
of your field and you still
you still willing to uh
to tackle the big questions in your own
way you're one of the one of the people
that represents
MIT best to me you've always been an
inspiration in that so it's good to hear
that you got that from your mom and dad
yeah you're too kind but but yeah I mean
the real the good reason to do science
is because you're really curious you
want to figure out the truth
if you think
this is how it is and everyone else says
no no that's and it's that way
you know
you sticked with what you think is true
and and
even if
everybody else keeps thinking it's
there's a certain
um
I always root for the underdog when I
watch movies and my my dad wants I I one
time for example when I wrote one of my
craziest papers ever or I'm talking
about our universe ultimately being
mathematical which we're not going to
get into today I got this email from a
quite famous Professor saying this is
not only but it's going to ruin
your career you should stop doing this
kind of stuff I sent it to my dad do you
know what he said what do you say he
replied with a quote from Dante
Corso
follow your own path and let the people
talk
go Dad yeah this is the kind of thing
he's dead but that that attitude is not
how did losing them as a man as a human
being change you
how does it expand your thinking about
the world how did it uh expand you
thinking about
you know this thing we're talking about
which is humans creating another living
sentient perhaps uh being
I think it uh
mainly do two things uh
one of them just going through all their
stuff after they had passed away and so
on just drove home to me how important
it is to ask yourselves
why are we doing this things we do
because it's inevitable that you look at
some things they spent an enormous time
on and you asked in hindsight would they
really have spent so much time on this
or if would they have done something
that was more meaningful
um so I've been looking more in my life
now and asking you know why am I doing
what I'm doing and I I feel
it should either be something I really
enjoy doing or it should be something
that I find really really meaningful
because it helps
Humanity
and the
if it's in none of those two categories
maybe I should spend less time on it you
know the other thing is dealing with
death up in person like this it's
actually made me less afraid
of
um
even less afraid of other people telling
me that I'm an idiot you know which
happens regularly and just let me live
my life do my thing you know
um
and um
it's made it a little bit easier for me
to focus on what I what I feel is really
important what about fear of your own
death
has it made it more real that this is
that this is something that happens
that's made it extremely real and you
know I'm next next in line in our family
now right it's me and my brother younger
brother but um
they both handled it with such dignity
it was that was a true inspiration also
they never complained about things and
you know when you're old and your body
starts falling apart it's more and more
to complain about they looked at what
could they still do that was meaningful
and they focused on that rather than
wasting time
talking about or even thinking much
about things they were disappointed in
I think anyone can make themselves
depressed if they start their morning by
making a list of grievances
whereas if you start your day when the
little meditation and just the things
you're grateful for you you basically
choose to be a happy person
because you only have a finite number of
days you should spend them Make It Count
being grateful yeah